بين الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن الدولي
دون استثناء على رفض اي تهجير قصري للسكان
الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه التباينات ظهرت
مع قله من الدول لا ترى في الحرب الجاريه
التي تشنها اسرائيل على سكان القطاع خطرا
بهذا
الشان اوضحت الولايات المتحده انه لا يجوز
الضغط على المدنيين لاجبارهم على مغادره
غزه تحت اي ظرف من الظروف
اننا نرفض بشكل قاطع تصريحاته بعض الوزراء
والمشرعين الاسرائيليين التي تدعو الى
اعاده توطين الفلسطينيين خارج غزه هذه
التصريحات الى جانب تصريحات المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين التي تدعو الى اساءه معامله
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين او تدمير غزه هي
تصريحات غير مسؤوله وتحريض ولا تؤدي الا
الى زياده صعوبه تامين السلام
الدائم على خلاف الموقف الامريكي ذهبت
مواق
العديد من الدول مثل روسيا والصين
والجزائر وفلسطين وغيرها الى ان الحرب
الجاريه في غزه هدفها دفع السكان الى
مغادره
اراضيهم من خلال القصف العشوائي المستمر
لبث الخوف والذعر بين المدنيين فاننا نرى
الاستراتيجيه الشامله للقدس الغربيه
لتهجير الفلسطينيين قصرا المنطق هنا هو
ببساطه ان يجعلوا الحياه في غزه لا تطاق
بل ومستحيله مما يت المدنيين امام خيار
مستحيل مغادره اراضيهم الاصليه او ان
يقتلون ان الطرد العنيف المستمر
للفلسطينيين من الضفه الغربيه وغزه سيهز
حتما منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا ما
يترتب على ذلك من عواقب وخيمه على العالم
اجمع ان القصف الهمجي
لغزه وتدمير البنيه
التحتيه
واستهداف كل ما يرمز
لحياه
بها من
الواضح انه يهدف الى جعلها مكان غير قابل
للحياه
وايضا قتل الامل بالعوده الى الديار في
نفوس
الفلسطينيين وهذا من اجل تسهيل وتنفيذ
مخطط تهجيرهم خارج
ارضهم مسؤولان اممي تحدث في الجلسه حذر من
ان الحرب الجاريه تخلق ظروفا تجعل من حياه
السكان في القطاع مستحيله وكذلك تجعل من
ايصال المساعدات اليهم امرا صعبا كذلك
والحل كما راه المسؤولان وكذلك جميع الدول
التي تحدثت باستثناء الولايات المتح
ووقف اطلاق النار